talk about your buddy's diet yeah sugar
chapelle sends me this
diet i know diet no no first of all real
quick i know diets
i've done you name a diet homeboy's done
it your friend with the gorgeous
hair and the body that won't quit i'll
give you that his body will not quit
and i love his body and i wish i looked
like him
what did he takes i'll take the diet you
sent me
let's just go over this so i'm trying to
lose weight it was
2 700 calories a day 300 grams of carbs
i what's his name mark mark silver fox
mark
listen you know you got a great body you
got a body for days oh you're talking so
i'm talking into the camera oh speaking
true you know god damn well i won't lose
weight at my weight
eating 300 grams of carbs a day
there's no way listen unless i'm working
out like he was saying
that was an example that he said we can
modify it yeah modify
well then i'll just do my own [ __ ]
he said he can consult with us and be
like okay just to get it understood he
didn't say that yeah
he did say that i didn't give you the
full like it was a full-on email yeah he
said it was he was happy i bought it i
saw now
it's enough oh okay this guy saw another
i love him you didn't read the whole
thing i saw that was like oh i
saw it i won't lose weight on this he
won't lose weight why would he give us
that then yeah if he knows we're losing
weight why would he give us that why
would he give you that huh i would love
to know
[ __ ] we would love to you know call him
up call him up bro
[Applause]
let me get shred like kim you will never
see me in t-shirts
oh yeah everybody i've been in jeans and
never
never never
he gonna answer yeah he's gonna answer
he's connecting so uh
there's that
[Music]
hey god dawg you got some tits on you
hello titty i wish everybody could see
you okay put this
but hey we're we're just going over the
diet cause me and chappelle started
today
i'm starting as well you're not on the
day
we're just going over it i just told you
i have some concerns because there's
almost 300 grams of carbs on there i'm a
little stressed out about it
um it was 277 to be exact
why'd you say 300. that's closer to 300
isn't it
you like to round up it's a guess let's
hear them have had success with both
low carb and i would consider at your
size that more moderate carb
yeah depending on
how much you want to work out i it's
really like a feeling thing it's like
do you feel like you need more carbs to
fuel the high intensity exercise there's
more
you can keep it at that if you like
being full more which i think is the big
benefit of keto that you feel full from
yeah
yeah you know um then we can ramp it
down and i can give you an example of
one that i've used that's like
you know the only carbs i eat are like
vegetables and
some blueberries yeah look at that see
initially like when i first started
getting lean i did keto and now
that i'm incorporating more like circuit
style high high intensity stuff where
i'm doing
kind of efficient like full body in like
30 minutes
i like a little more carbs because i
just feel like but you're you're burning
them right
you're using the carbs because you're
burning them for fuel
because you're burning those carbs off
right because you're doing the high
circuit training yeah
you're using it to optimize your
performance and i still think like you
know because a lot of people when
they're gaining like you see a
bodybuilder whatever
they're eating for 500 grams of carbs a
day i would still consider
like you know i have to look at what i
wrote down again maybe i missed i uh did
the math wrong but
um i would say for you guys i'd really
like you
around if you want to incorporate carbs
like 200
you know and then it's just about
adjustment because it's like if the
weights coming off
yeah then you can keep it there you know
what i mean yeah it's just that it's a
feel outcome parts are the easiest thing
to overdo so once you start eating rice
like it's easy back oh let me get a
little more rice hell yeah let me get a
little
more of this and that and then all of a
sudden you're 500
you know calories over your deficit
you're in a surplus and you're not
losing weight so
that's another benefit of keto is like
if you just don't eat any carbs you're
not thinking about carbs and you're not
craving carbs yeah it's almost easier
for me if i go like keto
like if i'm real strict and i just don't
touch the carbs usually the best way for
me
yeah so i can i'll i'll write you one
tonight then that um
you know would be the same amount of
calories
and i'll give you some options i like to
do keto when i do it i'll have like just
two big meals a day and i could eat
steak
yeah fried eggs that's where i'm at
brother
bacon yep perfect all right man we'll
wrap after this appreciate man
yeah yeah thanks brother to help you
guys out yeah hell yeah this is me
chapelle lacy
but yeah we'll uh i'll put i'll put us
in the group text so like yeah perfect
time well we'll have the uh
idea all right all right thanks mark you
everybody jane's popping son
all right that's that's mark what's
poppin
his nickname is what's poppin the veins
is poppin
he reminds me of ben stiller from
dodgeball yeah
oh really yeah gives you that vibes like
jack that's hilarious
right here he's so jazzed so jack just
distracting
i know right you can't even like talk to
me it's like put your shirt on dawg
but yeah you're right if you look if i
looked like that oh i'd never wear a
shirt never
you couldn't do i'd be burning my shirt
on stage my stage
my shirt would be off of all the time
would it be like cool you know
yeah yeah it'd be silly you're not like
you're instagram you have pictures with
your shirt off no i'm trying to get you
look at our instagram i'm sure we have
no pictures
i have one when i was keto and i was
pretty sure
oh yeah how long ago was this probably
three years ago they called me the keto
kid
it's weird people that don't keep up
like
or when i post something not cute like
oh what happened to keto i'm like [ __ ]
that was four years ago let's see oh
let's see
there i am oh you like tyson fury whoa
oh
[ __ ] brendan that was three years ago uh
pro i didn't say when i was posted
was that you in montana whoa look at my
man
dog i see some ass you ain't got that v
no more no i ain't got that he's
talking about that dick root though
there oh still there it's still there
2016. 2016 four years ago
you could just tell you was killing my
brother that's what i met you four years
ago
in 2016. well that's how i looked go to
that one
hits on me huh which one that that's
that was that was strict quito when his
own
straight up that was strict keto damn to
me if you want to lose weight fast keto
is the way
i don't think keto longevity can do it
how much you weigh
242 there 243 oh he wasn't sure a city
so you were shredded before you can get
back to it i would say that do you think
that's shredding i mean
you can get back to that for sure you
just don't have any abs i but i'm not
i've never been an ab guy
your shoulders look like mine that let's
take it easy
your shoulders don't look like this i
got boulders i don't think so okay
whatever
you know dude but yeah that's that's all
you all you're missing is the pack but
you like cut
you see you can see dude my job was to
work out
that's the difference like now like like
uh yesterday or saturday like i'll ride
my bike for 30 mile like
27 miles but it's just like that cardio
and that's like dude that was my
it's just different it was my job yeah
what if you just start riding your bike
30 miles and every
mile you just do 25 push-ups is that a
thought you could do that yeah
you can do that as well oh my jump
roping okay i've like added the
kettlebell into the workout okay
each round just do twenty-four yeah you
just gotta get your heart rate up but
literally but even take all that out of
it it's just about diet
diets ninety percent of losing weight
gosh that's a high percentage
at least that's the thing yeah but at
least you've been through
some people who don't i know i throw
some [ __ ] numbers
numbers on i'll throw something wild 98
gay are gay people in
[Applause]
with cheers glasses it's more believable
than that i know now i gotta believe it
like
i know yeah yeah yeah yeah like crazy
a lot of the uh reality like tv show
competitions too
like the they'll pay you like a little
bit for your time there but
it it's basically nothing like you have
to either win the competition
or you go home without like big brother
like big brother uh the challenge is
another one
big brother everybody
watching everybody i know ultimate
fighter you got paid
like they were they were counted as
amateur fights because they're only two
rounds
so that's how the news wouldn't get out
because if it's a sanctioned fight and
it was three rounds
news would get out so people would know
the results so the way they get around
that is by doing it as an amateur fight
yeah
it's two rounds and then you would get
five grand if you won
so if i fought three times i made 15
grand if you got a knockout you got an
extra bonus
how much finished everybody i fought so
i got another
so i probably doing the ultimate fire
thing which the biggest season they've
ever had
i was a finalist i probably made 30
grand
for six weeks of work is that good no
no it's not and i fought three monsters
damn would the loser get
if they fought and lost yeah did they
get anything like that i don't think
they get paid
yeah they win yeah can you imagine that
i think
again i don't want to cause any issues
with the ufc i'm pretty i don't think
they get paid
did they pay for their flight back home
oh yeah they covered like expenses
everything so
it was dope because there was like a
list like a
food list and i could put flaming young
lobster
salmon oh really they would bring it
like a few days later but if i put
buffalo trace whiskey or johnny walker
whiskey it would show up that
like an hour later because they want you
for the drama they want you drinking
like drunk oh yeah one of my homies
he does uh he's a pa on like some
reality shows or whatever and he says
like
they'll you know give you oh dude all
that oh
they get you they get you drunk a lot of
girls came out from
america's next top model saying the same
thing like they would be sleep deprived
they wouldn't be
fed all the time and so like you're
delirious but you have a lot of booze
you haven't been drinking
entertainment and then we do the
interview america just laughs at this
[ __ ]
yeah like that girl then they would do
the interview and they'd be like you
know
like they would like entice you like you
know material said that he doesn't think
you're very good on the ground
like he said that like he did how do you
feel about that you'd be a little drunk
like well that's [ __ ] up
and then you start talking [ __ ] yeah
it's so
weird man i can't wait for someone to be
like oh okay yeah
no no that's how i was like that's fine
it was fine all right
he's my friend i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
you wasn't great
he wasn't drinking back then no i didn't
touch it yeah
even if i was that show to me was
straight business i knew if i did well
in there i'd have a career
i took that thing so [ __ ] serious
yeah i only clean
food i got good sleep i wrote a journal
every night like to me i was like man if
i can
just make it to the finale i got a
[ __ ] career and you made it to the
footage
of finale yeah if it had all finishes in
the house i mean 16 people
had all what finishes i had uh two
knockouts
oh god i got i got it all finishers i
only had i only had four fights going in
the house it was a great time
a great time you can arm bar somebody
and [ __ ] no i uh uh anna kind of choked
uh d'amico rogers what is that anaconda
don't talk about your ding-a-ling well
let's see it you wanna say anna kind of
choke
all right yeah i kind of wanna see it
too okay you gonna do it
all right yeah he'll yeah do it on him
and i'll just watch
and do it i already tried already we
already we already went through is that
is that extra
medium hoodie not choking you out i know
right
it's my merch you can get it online hey
tap [ __ ]
and remember you gotta tell me to do it
standing
all right get on so let's say you shoot
in right you're shooting you shoot in on
me yeah right
yeah there you go go ahead so then i
mean i can do it from here just give me
a little feel so i don't have to turn
you ready
you know so crazy no no that's what he
did to me and uh
no you did that no so let's say we're
like in a scramble right and you like
shot in
and i defend it and you hang under this
leg that's what i'd look for all right
so i shoot i would shoot this arm
through see how it's across your neck
yeah
yeah grab my bicep and then they call
this a gatoro and put my head underneath
like an alligator
okay i roll like this you're gonna roll
too
you gotta roll two fool i'm wrong but
watch how much tighter this
[ __ ] hey bro he tapped
so you can't go anywhere you would want
to be going somewhere oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay okay he tapped okay
in the heavyweight division whatever you
choked out so i could dig him when he
said
mitrione no he didn't survive he tapped
no i'm saying like how are you feeling
now we got to check on this well being
yeah yeah
that's